REBECCA MOORE: Good
afternoon, everyone.
Welcome to Academics at Google.
My name's Rebecca Moore, and I'm
the lead for the Google Earth
Engine and Earth
Outreach projects.
It's my great pleasure to
introduce Randy Sargent, whom
I've known since 2005
when we worked together
on publishing some innovative
layers in Google Earth, which
allowed people to fly in
seconds from outer space
to see the eyelashes on a camel.
He's currently holding
dual appointments
on the faculty at
Carnegie Mellon University
and also here at Google.
As a visiting scientist with
my Google Earth Engine team,
Randy's helping to research and
develop time-lapse explorable
maps, including a recently
released time-lapse animation
of the entire earth from 1984
to 2012, which was mosaiced
for more than two million
Landsat satellite images.
Earlier this year Timelapse
won the People's Choice Webby
for best use of moving
images and video on the web.
As a senior system scientist
at CMU's Create Lab,
Randy researches for
the Explorables Project,
developing ways to interactively
explore and understand
large data sets and
complex systems, including
air and water quality and
employment in economic trends.
Prior to CMU and Google, Randy
helped develop planetary Rover
software at NASA, and he
received his BS and MS
from MIT.
So welcome, Randy.
RANDY SARGENT:
Thank you, Rebecca.
Thank you, Rebecca,
and thanks so much
for everyone being here.
So most of what I'm
going to talk about
is the work of two different
teams-- the Earth Engine
team here at Google and
also the Explorables
team at Carnegie Melon
University's Create Lab.
First I want to really
dig into Earth Engine
and get you motivated
about why it's so cool
and why it really
motivated those of us
at CMU to come here and
work on this project.
Earth Engine in a
very, very short form
is what happens when you
take all of the images that
come from the many dozens
of scientific spacecraft
orbiting the planet
run by the US
government and
other governments,
take the data out of
these sorts of archives,
and put them into this sort of
place, which is a Google data
center where we put all of
the image data co-located
with the CPU to actually
process that data.
One of the earliest projects
but the Earth Engine team
undertook with the entire
corpus of Landsat images
that go back over 40
years now is can we
build cloud-free mosaics
of the entire planet?
Now cloud-free mosaics
in some places are easy,
but this place in particular
is in the middle of Brazil.
It's a very, very
rainy and cloudy place.
Up until recently,
the best you could do
were pictures kind of like this.
So now without the clouds.
And here's all of South America.
This is the best we could do
prior to the Earth Engine.
This is painstakingly
mosaicing kind
of the best of all
the Landsat scenes.
But with Earth
Engine what we can do
is statistically go through
entire stacks with Landsat
and find all the places
around the clouds.
So we can kind of
combine different pieces
of different scenes together
and build a cloud-free mosaic
of all of South America
that looks like this.
So one of the
first deliverables,
if you will, from Earth Engine
was a new cloud-free base
map that you see today in Google
Maps and Google Earth both.
What else can you do with
this entire petabyte scale
archive of remote
sensing data and images?
What other sorts of
analysis can be performed?
One of the early successes is
this publication in science.
And with it comes the
following data product, which
is a map of forest change
across the planet from 2000
into present day.
And this is a map where
we can zoom in all the way
to 30 meters per pixel.
So if we zoom in to the Amazon
rainforest, for example,
we'll see a lot of these
red areas down below,
which are places where the
forest has been going away.
The bright green
areas are places
where the forest was there
both at the beginning
and also the end
of the sequence.
And you'll see
some places in blue
where a forest
actually reappeared.
We can go around the
entire planet this way.
We can take a look at the
southeastern United States
where you see a lot red,
you see a lot of blue,
and then you see-- so red
and blue are places where
the first has gone
and then come back.
And purple actually
is places where
it's changed both directions.
So these are places that
are heavily forested
but tend to go back
after cutting down.
One of the really
important things
about taking this incredible
archive of imagery
and turning it into
this product is
we're turning data
into knowledge.
We're taking this
stack of images
and be able to provide
analysis on top
to be able to say things like
the rate of deforestation
over these 12 years in
Brazil has been going down.
So it's been decelerating.
Whereas in Indonesia,
the rate of deforestation
has been accelerating.
So let me jump in to what
it's like to actually write
some code inside Earth Engine.
And I want to show you just
a very short example which
is one of my favorites.
You may recognize this
as lights at night,
and if we go around
the planet you
can see yes, it looks
like lights at night.
But if I bring it
up to layers, there
are actually two
different years here.
So I can switch back and forth
between showing 1992 and 2012.
We can zoom into Europe
here and see the difference.
You can see that by in
large 2012 is brighter.
But let's do a little bit
of analysis on top of that.
So let's switch.
Let's add some more code.
This is the code
what it looks like.
We're going to
basically instantiate
the collection of all of
the lights at night images.
We're going to attach
some time stamps to them.
Then we're going to
do a linear regression
across every pixel in the map.
So every pixel we're
going to look back
to 1992 and through present
day and make a linear fit.
And then we're going to
go add that to the map
and visualize it.
This is what we have.
So let me try and
explain what it
is where we're looking at here.
We're seeing lights at night.
You can see where the lights
and where they're not.
But the hue is now
encoding whether the lights
are increasing or decreasing.
The red areas are
areas of increase,
and you can see
a few places that
are very strong in the red.
So up here we have
Poland, for example,
or all of China,
the southern part
of India-- lots of
interesting places.
Places of blue are places where
we're decreasing the lights.
And perhaps we can zoom in
here to a really blue area.
And if we turn it
of for a moment
and you look--
see here's Poland.
Let's turn off and see
where we are on the map.
It's this big, blue area that's
been in the news recently.
So this is Ukraine.
So Ukraine is in the middle of
Poland, Romania, and Russia,
which are all showing
a lot of increase.
This is right on the border.
So lots of really interesting
things you can see in this map.
I want to zoom into
the United States.
And you'll see
places where there's
a lot of growth around
the urban areas.
So for example, Dallas Fort
Worth area we see a lot of red
where the lights
have been increasing.
We've been increasing
the urbanization--
the urban footprint there.
And in the Northeast, we
see a lot of bluer areas.
And what's going on there?
Have we really been
losing population?
Only in a few places.
For example, Pittsburgh lost
a little bit of population
during this time,
but not a whole lot.
Turns out what we're
seeing here, by in large,
is a side effect of energy
efficiency and reduction
of light pollution.
So if you want to
illuminate your streets
and you're highways,
you want all the photons
to be going down and
not so much going up.
So as we've been doing that
more and more efficiently,
you can see the
evidence from space.
Let me switch gears a bit.
So I talked about Earth
Engine and kind of what's cool
and how you can get involved
like very, very quickly
and do some interesting stuff.
I want to switch
gears and now talk
about kind of the
other team that's
come together in this project.
So at the Carnegie Melon
Create Lab where I work,
we do a lot of different
sorts of projects,
mostly around empowerment
of public and communities,
around technology, around
data, around understanding.
Rebecca alluded to the
Explorables project.
This is a project
that we're working on
to try to make especially
time series data,
whether it's perhaps time series
images of the planet or time
series other sorts
of things explorable
and more understandable.
So when we got together
and combined Explorables
with what Earth Engine was
starting to put together,
let me show you kind of
what came out of that.
I'm going to zoom
out of this map
and make it full screen here.
Do you remember that the
cloud-free mosaic that
was built out of all
the Landsat scenes?
What we've done
here in Earth Engine
is build not one
cloud-free mosaic,
but 29 cloud-free mosaics.
So now we have an
animated map, if you will.
We've taken the 29, and
we're playing through them
in a video.
So where kind of a normal
Google Maps or Google Earth
you can zoom in
and see something,
here we can zoom in
and see it change.
So let's zoom in, for
example, to Southwestern US.
This is Las Vegas.
So you see over
the 29 years here,
Las Vegas is growing a lot.
And we can zoom in even
further and see kind
of in great detail
what's happening.
We can see the suburbs forming
and expanding outwards.
We can see how the runways
have to double up here
in the airport.
We also have pan to the
east and look at Lake Mead.
So this is the site
of the Hoover Dam.
And at that same 29 years
when Las Vegas is growing,
Lake Mead is shrinking.
So you can see this thing
starts off as an island,
and it's not an
island by the end.
So you can see, in
several different ways,
our footprint on the earth here.
Let's move down to
South America where
we were looking at some of
the deforestation analysis.
Let's zoom in kind of as far
as Landsat will let us go.
We're in the Brazilian
state of Rondonia.
And I'm going to slow down the
animation a little bit here.
Let's go to super slow here.
You'll see initially the
roads all start to be built.
And around the roads
there are these farms.
And understand that from left to
right here, from east to west,
we're talking about
maybe 50 kilometers.
So these are big farms that are
being cut out of the forest,
primarily for soybean
or for raising cattle.
You can see a small
town is forming
in the middle of the image here.
Let's zoom out a bit.
So now we're seeing
maybe a quarter
of the Brazilian
state of Rondonia.
We're going to speed back up.
And you can see this
road stretch out
and how quickly this
entire area kind of fills.
You can also see some
interesting shapes appear.
So now we're looking at the
entire state of Rondonia.
And you'll see these
funny little cutout areas.
And we're going to get back
to these in a little while.
But just keep in mind
that deforestation is not
happening everywhere, but it's
happening a lot of places.
Let's zoom out even further.
Now we can clearly
see the Amazon River.
We can see a lot of
different things.
But if you look along the
southern extent of the Amazon,
you see it retreating.
And the scale is--
first time I saw
this I was blown away,
because I didn't understand
that if you could look at
it from space like this,
you could still
see it happening.
It's that big, what's going on.
So I'm going to zoom
in to another spot.
So now we're at the tributaries
to the Amazon in Bolivia.
And we're right off of
the Andes Mountains.
And here you see a different
sort of thing happening.
Watch the rivers go.
These are called meanders,
and the river is meandering.
And what that means is that
as the sedimentation comes
from the Andes and
gets deposited,
the river actually
changes its banks.
It moves to different places.
And you'll see in places
where the rivers loop back so
far that they meet
themselves and they end up
orphaning these little
ringed lakes that
are called oxbow lakes.
And if we follow this,
we can follow this
all the way to the Amazon and
see this really impressive
change happening.
Moving a little bit to the west
here and to be east in Bolivia
and you'll see another spot.
And this is a spot where it's
really quite complicated what's
going on.
So let me play it through
a few times faster
and then I'll slow
it down a bit.
So you see a lot of
deforestation happening.
You see a lot of forest
turning into farm.
But this river is doing
something kind of crazy.
You see, the river is actually
breaking free of its banks
and going a different
path, and then
you've got a third
path over here.
And if we slow it
down even further,
you'll see as it breaks
free of it's path--
I'm going to pull back in
time just a little bit--
so it breaks to its
new path, it actually
floods this entire area.
So this area which had
been farming basically
got completely washed out.
So let's watch it again slowly.
And this is one of the things
that rivers do in areas
where they're
depositing sedimentation
over a large area.
So they evulse and they
switch between path and path,
and they're basically
just dumping
sedimentation over this
entire area over time.
You see the same thing
like in river deltas.
Let's look at some other things
that the water is doing here.
So we're going to
get to Cape Cod.
This is the south
end of Cape Cod.
Let's speed it back up.
What you see here is
the way that the beach
is changing over time.
You'll see places where
things break through.
the beach has rebuilt.
And you'll see that by in
large, most of the sand
is moving towards the south.
You can see similar
sorts of things
on the outer banks
of North Carolina.
Let's go zoom in there.
Let's move to Iran, where
we can see Lake Urmia.
Lake Urmia is a very large
lake, but it's been shrinking.
And most of the water that
has been historically going
into the lake is
now being diverted
into these agricultural areas.
So you can see--
you know, first you
notice that the lake is
shrinking over these 29 years,
but you can see these
kind of green areas
around on each side, and that's
where the water has been going.
Because the water's
been retreating,
the water becomes
more salty, things
like fertilizer and
pesticide concentrate,
so it becomes less and
less good water for using.
So you actually have,
in the tributaries,
these sorts of dams being
built and new lakes being
formed to provide
more clean water.
And of course that diverts even
more water from Lake Urmia.
So Lake Urmia's days
are numbered I fear.
Move over to Aral Sea.
Aral Sea is the
same sort of thing
happening, but on a
much larger scale.
Lake Urmia is much,
much larger-- I mean,
Aral Sea is much
larger than Lake Urmia,
but the same thing is happening.
So we have-- we zoom out of it.
We have these agricultural
areas where most of the water's
being diverted.
Now let's zoom in on it to one
corner of the agriculture here.
And this is a place
where you sort of reach
a peak of the irrigation.
You can see, initially,
this wasn't farmed.
It sort of, you
know, spread out.
I'm going to slow
this down a bit.
You see it turns green, but then
it turns gray towards the end.
So this tried to maybe
overreach it a little bit here.
Let's move to Saudi
Arabia, another place where
we're irrigating
in a very dry area.
All the water for this
center pivot irrigation
is being taken from wells--
from water that was put there,
you know, eons ago, so it's not
being replaced very quickly.
So this can't last for long.
You can see kind of how
crazy the extent of this is.
Let's move from water to fire.
Let's move to Australia.
If you look closely
here you'll see
all these scars
appear from burns.
And it's like the
areas actually become
lighter when the underlying
ground is shown after the burn.
Let me slow this down a bit.
Now you can see for each one
of these fires kind of roughly
where it started, what
direction the wind was going,
and you can kind of see
the different paths here.
Let's move to other disasters.
Let's go to Mount Pinatubo.
So this is the Caldera.
And you can see-- and I'm going
to just grab the slider here
and move it all the
way back and hit play.
And you'll see, as this
appears, all the rivers
of ash kind of going every
which way from Mount Pinatubo.
Let's move to do glaciers.
And we're going to go to Alaska
here to Mendenhall Glacier.
However, over these
29 years, we can
see a lot of glacial
changes-- a lot
of evidence of climate change.
So here, as we zoom
in, you can see
that the front
line of the glacier
retreating slowly
during the 29 years.
Let me go back up here.
Let's move to Columbia
Glacier, also in Alaska.
Columbia Glacier has a
very impressive retreat.
It retreated tens of kilometers,
starting from here then
all the way back.
Now I'm going to
speed this back up.
It's a little harder
to see when I speed up,
but I want to show you another
thing that's happening.
So if we go to the glacial
tributaries, if you will,
these rivers of ice that are
emerging into Columbia Glacier,
watch closely and you will
see how the ice is moving.
You'll see the motion
of these rivers
coming together and then
draining out into the sea.
Let's move to another glacier
where that's even more obvious.
This is Malaspina Glacier.
There's not a lot of
retreat happening here,
but you can see kind of how the
river-- how the ice is dumped
toward the top and then
moves slowly in these waves
out into the ocean.
We started with
Las Vegas, but I'd
like to show you some
other cities now.
This is Shanghai.
And this area here is where
Shanghai Proper was in 1984.
And you can see, as we
go through our 29 years,
that by the end, it's kind of
hard to tell where Shanghai
ends and other things begin.
The size of what we're looking
at surely dwarfs Las Vegas.
You can see incredible
amounts of land being added.
You can zoom in here and watch.
Let's move a bit south
to the Pearl River Delta.
That's a sight of a lot of
electronics manufacture.
And Hong Kong is
right about here.
You can see over these 29 years,
we go from a lot of farmland
to huge urban expansion.
Let's move to Dubai.
Dubai is one of the
most impressive sites
of engineering new land.
So we can look at the
islands being built here.
Let's slow that one
down up too and zoom in.
These are the Palm Islands.
There are two sets.
I'm going to hit pause and
just drag to the very end here.
You can see both.
Then let's look up
here to the north.
These are the World Islands.
If you look closely you can
see how they map to the world.
I'm going to move
now to the place
where I grew up--
Dallas Fort Worth.
And Dallas Fort Worth has an
incredible amount of sprawl.
Sizewise, it's
growing quite rapidly,
but it's not very
dense population-wise.
So here we have
Dallas on the right
and Fort Worth on the left.
And if we go up
north, you'll see
just incredible
suburbifications.
Is that a word?
So let's pan to the west.
And to the west here, if you
look really closely-- now we're
north of Fort Worth--
in the last roughly five
or six years of animation,
you see these kind
of funny little white dots.
And I'm not sure
how many people are
able to see the white dots
from where you're sitting.
Those white dots are fracking.
So those are
actually paths where
we're doing hydraulic
fracturing looking for oil.
This is the Barnett
Shale in Forth Worth.
And it's both north and
south of Fort Worth.
So if you look around, you'll
find this stuff pretty much
everywhere, including right
in the middle of urban areas.
Let's move to Colorado.
It's another site where there's
a lot of hydraulic fracturing
happening.
So once again, you can
see the pads appear.
Here we also have to build
the roads to get to the paths.
Another type of resource
extraction in West Virginia
is mountaintop removal.
So let's take a pan
over there and start
all the way zoomed in.
So mountaintop removal is
exactly what it sounds like.
We're taking the
tops of mountains,
removing them, putting them in
the valleys, and all the land
that were moving, we sift
through it for coal, basically.
And you can see kind
of how devastating this
is to the area.
It's also fairly unsafe in
terms of the water supply.
And you've heard some
fairly high profile problems
with that.
Now let me zoom out of it.
That thing we started
off is just there.
And now we're seeing
kind of it's everywhere.
I'll zoom out some more.
You can see it's the expanse
of mountaintop removal.
And we're not talking about
10 or even just 100 spots.
Were talking about hundreds.
Another type of resource
extraction-- this is also coal.
This is open pit.
You can see as we're digging
through, looking for coal,
we're taking what
comes out and then
putting it where
the last bit was.
So it kind of moves around
almost like a video game.
Let's move to Alberta,
Canada, and look
at some of the things
happening around the tar sands.
This is a huge facility.
I do not know what all
the different pieces are.
Now you're looking
at the tar sands,
but if you look to
the east here you'll
see something that kind
of catches your eye.
So this is logging.
So we're cutting down
trees here for the wood.
And if you look
closely, you'll see
that they get cut down twice--
once right at the beginning,
and once at the end.
And if you watch
it, you'll actually
see that it's an
alternating pattern.
So kind of the
evens were cut first
and the odds were cut later.
Let's look at another place
that's in active logging.
This is in Washington state.
We're seeing clear
cut in small patches.
And then those slowly grow back
and then get clear cut again.
So I said that we were going
to loop back to the Amazon
and look at some of the
patterns of deforestation there.
So let's do that.
Remember these
shapes-- especially
if we zoom into Rondonia here--
these funny little places where
people don't seem to
be cutting down trees.
Let's turn on part
of the story here.
This is the world database
of protected areas.
And in green, we have kind
of every region that's
been recorded by Brazil
as a protected area.
Now, different protected
areas are different.
But this one in particular
belongs to a native people,
the [INAUDIBLE], who Rebecca
and the Earth Outreach team
have worked with
personally in Brazil.
You'll see that
this is territory
that belongs to them
that's been set aside
by the Brazilian government.
It is illegal to
cut down trees here.
But you can see
it happens anyway.
You can see if we zoom in
people try to come in, sometimes
in the middle of the night, and
try to chop down some trees.
My understanding is that
the peoples in this area
have moved most of their
population to the borders
to try and prevent that.
And so they're trying to
police their own borders
and keep the illegal
loggers out right now.
To me, this shows like
a very different story
than the kind of
depressing story
that I saw initially when I
first saw the deforestation.
And you can also
start to see how
it might be that
Brazil is trying
to decelerate its deforestation.
In places, we're
actually bumping right
into the areas that
have been set aside,
either for indigenous
peoples or for other reasons.
Look around.
Other spots, same story.
Here we are in [INAUDIBLE].
In this area that
kind of sprouts out,
it almost like balloons
like an evil flower here.
But it's basically steering
clear of these protected areas.
And we have this database
now for the entire planet.
So let's go take a
look at other spots.
If we get to-- let's go
back to Washington state.
We're going to look
at a reservation,
Native American reservation, in
Washington state-- the Quinault
Reservation.
It's not protected nearly the
same way as the [INAUDIBLE].
You can't really
tell the difference.
Let's move to another
spot in the US.
There's a spot where
policy changed partway
through the animation.
So look closely here.
And at the beginning, you'll
see pretty much everything
is being deforested equally
between the left and the right.
And towards the end,
you'll see a border appear.
It's a little hard to see.
But to the right is actually
the Clearwater National Forest.
And by and large,
forests are not
protected from
being chopped down.
Though, sometimes there
are different policies
inside the National
Forest than outside.
Let's move to Indonesia.
We're going to zoom in
to Tesso Nilo, which
was made somewhat famous by the
recent Showtime climate change
series.
This is the protected area.
And you can't really
see the border at all.
If we go to 2012,
you can't really
tell what's been protected
and what hasn't been.
So that's the end
of the Landsat.
Let me switch gears and move
to some other things here.
One of the new areas
that we're pushing on
is what to do when you want to
visualize large amounts of data
that's not raster,
that's not image-based.
And you'll see here we have
like maybe 3 million different
protected areas.
But that's kind of small.
We're worried about,
like what about tens
of millions, hundreds of
millions, billions of things
which are not raster pixels?
So you've probably
seen things that
look a little bit
like this up on top
or up on the bottom here.
Or you've seen heat maps, which
are fairly low resolution.
But I want to call your
attention back to the lights
at night.
I want you to think
about lights at night
for a moment as
something different.
So it is a raster product.
It comes from a
raster satellite.
But think about it not as
raster, but as a visualization.
A really awesome visualization
of a billion light sources,
or billions of light sources.
And I think you'll agree this
is superior to any of the three
things we just saw.
So you're seeing an amazing
amount of expressivity.
You're seeing quite clearly
where the cities are.
You're seeing the
spider web of things
that are joining the cities,
the interstate highways,
some things of that nature.
You can even see like around
Chicago here, this funny area
where we start to color
out into Lake Michigan.
So this is actually--
yeah, an optical effect
of normal camera systems.
When the light gets
super-super bright,
the apparent image
starts to bleed outwards.
And there a few different
mechanisms of that.
The most common is simply that
when photons hit the lens,
they may or may not scatter.
And you try and keep the
lens as clean as possible
to keep that from
happening too much.
Though when you have a lot
of brightness in the middle,
you start to see that.
So for normal people,
when they look at this,
they will tell you that that
pixel here right off of-- right
in the middle of Chicago
is brighter than this pixel
down here.
And it turns out it's not
actually true [INAUDIBLE]
saturating the monitor.
But you're inferring
from that because we're
talking the language of optics.
Our eyes do the same thing.
So we're kind of born
with this knowledge
that this must have
been brighter than this.
Other things that you
can really express well
here are things that kind
of jump out as surprises.
So if you look here, you can see
Chicago, Minneapolis, St. Paul.
You have this weird
thing over here.
And even if you didn't
know enough geography
to know that there's
not really a city there,
it doesn't look right.
It doesn't look the same
as the other cities.
So you might think, well,
why don't we zoom in here?
And you look a little closer and
you say, what's going on here?
You see all these strange
horizontal bands and you
wonder, what does that mean?
The first time I saw it, I
thought it was an artifact.
I thought it was an
error of the satellite.
We'll get back to that.
So I want to show you
the first visualization
we built kind of using
that as an inspiration.
So I'm going to
stop the animation
and go straight to the end.
And this is a visualization
of about 20 million
well pads from drilling
for oil and gas.
This is in Pennsylvania.
We can zoom out and take
a look at other places.
And we're kind of doing the
same sort of trick where
if there are a lot
of them together,
we start to make them brighter.
Then we start to
make them bleed out.
So it kind of transitions
from individual points
you might see into a heat
map kind of on the fly,
if you will.
As we zoom in here and
grab the animation slide,
and we go through just
the past few years,
you'll see all the
fracking that's
happening in Pennsylvania.
So these horizontal bands
over here are all fracking.
We can go back to
Dallas, Fort Worth.
And we can look at
what was going on
with all these strange
lights up in North Dakota.
And it turns out, if you look
closely-- I'll switch to map.
That's a little easier to see.
Sure enough, all
these wells were
being drilled in these
horizontal bands.
Like, what's up with that?
So you zoom in a bit more, you
see these are all on the roads.
And even in places where
you don't see the road,
it's just because our maps'
not quite up to date yet.
So these are also places
where we're fracking.
North Dakota is
unusual because we're
fracking for oil
rather than gas.
And we're just throwing
away the gas that comes out.
So a third of the
carbon that comes out
of the ground from
North Dakota is burned.
So it's being sent straight
into the atmosphere.
Let's keep moving on.
So what if we have
a lot of vector data
that we can animate?
What we're looking at
here is fires from space.
And you watch closely
and you'll see
different sorts of
things happening.
You'll see if we
zoom in to Africa,
you'll see that a
year's worth of fire
that we're cycling
through, you'll
see fires up here in
the North of the equator
and to the South of the equator.
Let's turn on satellite and you
can kind of see in the middle,
we have like this
really dense forest.
But these are agricultural
areas up in the North
and up in the South.
And this is a form
of agriculture
called swidden agriculture.
So these are fires
being set by people.
We can look over here
between India and Nepal
and see kind of
every year, it kind
of marches up from Southeast
Asia up here with the seasons.
So you do this
kind of once a year
to prepare the ground for
the next year's growing.
You can also see
other sorts of things.
You can see things that are
not changing so much over time.
You see these very bright areas.
And you see that a lot of them
in the Middle East-- and you
can imagine what they are.
So these are all
flaring from oil wells.
So we can zoom in
here and actually
see on the satellite
kind of what
it must look like on the ground.
And you can see
these things on fire.
These are very dirty fires
in this particular spot.
And once again, we have
this amazing flaring
happening in North Dakota.
We have it two other
places happening
in Texas, where there's
a lot of flaring.
But curiously, there
isn't much flaring
around Dallas, Fort Worth.
Because it's so close to people,
they actually spend the extra
to collect everything
and not burn it.
What if we combine that
visualization of fires
with a satellite map that
also can animate over
the course of a year?
Let me show you the
same spot in Africa.
So unlike the earlier
animation that we
saw was built from Landsat,
this is built from MODIS.
And it's still a prototype
right now, but what we can see
is the seasonality of the brown
and the green in this area
and kind of how in phase
the fires are with it.
We can do the same
thing up here.
So with that, let me loop back
and get to my last slide here.
So moving back to timelapse
and kind of the experience
we had putting this together
with the Earth Engine
team, the success we had
with "Time" magazine.
It really brings home to
me the reasons we did this,
the reason we decided
to do this together,
and kind of all the amazing
things that kind of I
observed working with
the Earth Engine team.
It is an incredible group of
really talented and capable
people.
Couple that with Google's
infrastructure and ability
to scale computation and
ability to take the results
that we built and get
them out to the world.
As Rebecca said, the
Landsat Timelapse project
won a Webby with
"Time" magazine.
And we've had many millions
of people come visit.
But I want you to kind
of really meditate
on some of these
numbers that I'm
showing you here
up on the slide.
This is the amount
of computation
that we found lying around
to build those entire 29
mosaics and all the
videos around them.
I think it wouldn't
surprise you to say
that I couldn't find
this lying around CMU.
So I think it brought home kind
of in many different dimensions
why it was important to work
together and kind of how
blessed I feel to be
part of this effort.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Any questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So two million
hours of computation,
is that [INAUDIBLE]?
RANDY SARGENT: Yeah,
two million core hours.
So yeah.
Other questions?
Jeff.
AUDIENCE: It's nice to see--
it's kind of startling just
to see what's happening
with the earth.
It's nice to see the
optimistic of a tribe that
is out there protecting
their land or their forest.
Do you expect to find
more things like that?
RANDY SARGENT: Yeah.
I mean, it's worth
actually spending
hours looking at Brazil.
Brazil is doing a
really good job of this.
And it really
becomes obvious why
the deforestation
is slowing down.
Because really, they're hitting
the wall in a lot of places.
And that's not true
everywhere, but it
shows that when we decide to
set a policy for good reasons,
things can change.
We have control.
There's not this
inexorable progression
until all the trees are gone.
AUDIENCE: Have you seen
instances of governments
actually use these really
powerful visualizations
for actual policy making?
RANDY SARGENT: The question
is, have we seen places
where the governments
are using this?
And it's starting to happen.
I mean, we're starting to
see in places that people
are starting to
actually look at this.
I know that here
in the US, this has
gone to congressional
subcommittees.
And I think we're
going to see more
and more of that happening.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Follow-up
to that question.
[INAUDIBLE]?
RANDY SARGENT: So I think you're
asking kind of how many people
are looking at it, like
how is it being used?
AUDIENCE: How [INAUDIBLE]?
RANDY SARGENT: It's a
really good question.
Earth Engine is a
complicated thing.
So we've been focusing
on the timelapse
for the last little bit here.
Earth Engine itself,
in terms of researchers
using the platform
to do analysis
based on kind of this incredible
archive of images connected
to all the
computation, the usage
looks a little bit like
a hockey stick right now.
So we're seeing more
and more people.
So you saw the initial
science publication
led by Matt Hanson
and a group of people
actually here at Google.
You're seeing many,
many people kind
of following in those
sort of footprints.
So you're seeing an explosion
of analytical results.
And my hope, an explosion in
visual results as well, so
that we can reach out not
only to researchers but also
to policymakers and to
the public altogether.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Are all the
web apps that you showed
publicly accessible?
RANDY SARGENT:
Everything I showed
you is publicly accessible,
with the exception of the World
Database of Protected Areas.
Everything else I
showed you was public.
AUDIENCE: Is that
connected somehow?
RANDY SARGENT: We haven't
gotten to the point where
we have a public
version of that.
AUDIENCE: When you were doing
math on the [INAUDIBLE]?
RANDY SARGENT: The math being
done kind of on the fly when
we were doing kind of
the linear regression
on the lights, that's being
done on the server side.
So you can potentially have
very, very complicated--
that was accessing
maybe 30 images
over a sequence of years.
Sometimes, you'll be
doing calculations
over maybe a stack of
500, or 1,000, or more.
So it really needs to
happen in the cloud.
And then, that computation is
basically being done on demand.
So you don't do it
for the whole planet.
You do it for the part that
you're looking at in the map.
And as you zoom in, each tile
is being built on the fly.
Another question?
AUDIENCE: Will you be
updating this data over time?
RANDY SARGENT: Will it be
updating data over time?
Yes.
Any more questions?
Thank you, everyone.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
RANDY SARGENT: Oh, sorry.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Are you
planning in the future--
like the fracking
example, [INAUDIBLE]
trying to esitmate what
the carbon footprint is
[INAUDIBLE]?
RANDY SARGENT: The
question is, what
are sort of value-added
products that
can be done on top
of the fracking data?
Like if we know where all
the wells are being drilled,
what can you compute from that?
And that's an area where
Earth Engine is now
branching out into.
It's very, very strong in
the raster computation now.
But Earth Engine is starting
to build analytical tools that
will answer exactly that.
To be able to
answer things like,
what is the rate of change
of the drilling wells?
What sort of impact
might they have?
Let's intersect that with local
populations that are downwind
and things of that nature.
So those are the sorts of things
being added to Earth Engine
right now.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]